It's painful
To know quantity
Things that are not useful and which you do, and I'll give you an example
Well, I've done it many times before in lectures full of students that usually talked about professional development
How long do you waste it, and then ask them to vote: How many of you spend 10 hours a day?
Almost 10% of the students have raised their hands, and this is interesting since I have not explained to them what is in particular a waste of time
I just asked the question and all of them did the same analysis. I did not say you lost 10 hours of your day
I just ask to express your own behavior how many hours are lost 10 hours a day
Almost 10% of people raised their hands
Well what about 6 hours a day?
80% of people have raised their hands and now to settle accounts
Well I like to do these calculations with people but they often hate doing accounts, but I like to do them
Well 6 hours a day
It is 42 hours a week, to transfer 40 working hours. Well these hours work, now to move
What is the value of your time?
You are now a student at the university or of course worth less payoff
But it is worth much more than that if you take advantage of one productive hour at the age of 20
You will get the benefits of this clock until the end of your life
And this cumulative effect of the hours that we exploit in young people and so I say
Suppose the value of your time is $ 50 per hour, although I think more of it but suppose this
We can say 25, but we said $ 50. That's $ 2000 a week you're wasting. Which is 100,000 per year
This would have been your life if you had not lost 100,000 a year
Well, but what after 40 years?
4 million, you will be rich. You even do not learn this stop wasting your time
Then people shake their heads ah never thought this way never. But yes
Think about it this way and do not waste your life, then think why people resist this message
Okay
You really want to wake up from your stupidity and discover that you are missing half of your life
When people waste their time they really hate doing it
I have known many people in my clinical practice of people who constantly procrastinate, and they do
Follow videos for example, but not the clips that are useful to them. Except sometimes
But they just move unconsciously like you do when you try to kill time without concentration or indifference
People who do it feel bad. They become depressed and feel anxious. They can not get rid of it
They feel almost addicted. What do you say about social networking sites now. What do you do with young people?
Sure, but there is the feeling of rot and internal corruption that accompanies it
It's like saying you're wasting your life. That is why it is painful
It is painful to notice this and then think, my God, how uncontrolled I am
I do not know anything. I can not use this to organize my time. I can not stick to a schedule
I have no goals. I do not know anything about the world
True, maybe there is a part of me
I feel bitterness because I have not done anything yet, and I would say that I do not care
And this is your understanding of what I was absent from it and this makes you corrupt and and
And trustworthy and that view that no one wants to be sure
But
You are the worst alternatives